- Oh my god, this bitch's feed is so fake.
- How do you know that's its fake?
- I'm an American and I'm 15.
Why do you ask?
I thought you were too
good for the internets.
What?
- Hey, do you think you
could get yourself home?
- Can I pick up my phone
and request an Uber?
Yeah, I think I can manage that.
What's your Insta, or do
you only have a Finsta?
- I'm a little behind the times.
- Clearly, are you like, lady,
come on how many photos does it take?
Crazy thing is, she
never posts any of 'em.
That's like gotta be a diagnosis, right?
How do you even function
in a world without art?
Don't say you get in
books, books take too long.
Oh my god, you're so kind
and you're so protective.
You're like my daddy.
Is that what you like to hear?
- No.
- Do you wanna fuck me, William.
No, nevermind.
- Oh yeah, of course you
do, of course you do.
Everybody wants to fuck the 15-year-old.
- Is that my shirt,
that's my fucking shirt.
- Looks hotter on me though.
I thought you were like, hip.
- Honestly, I'm more of a book guy.
- Why are you robbing your eyeballs
of all things that are good?
Feeds that aren't lame
help people understand you.
But don't overshare, like, your breakfast.
Unless I don't know, is
breakfast your brand?
- I don't know that I have a brand.
- It's not that deep.
If it's interesting, take a pic.
Don't filter, don't hashtag.
Hashtags are thirsty.
That's literally the
handbook of being dope
in a sea of basic losers,
which most people are.
Just lean into your thing,
Will, but in a not try-hard,
yet you're low-key
fascinating kind of way.
That's how you get her
to fall in love with you.
- What?
- That's why you're doing it, right?
You like someone.
- No.
- That's the only reason
anyone posts anything.
Please be not disappointing
on your Instagram.
Hey, just because you're
dripping in hoo-hah,
doesn't mean you're all that.
Can you believe she put that
spy software on my phone.
- So, you're not gonna tell her you know?
- Obviously not.
It's way more useful if she
thinks it's still working.
- This is what I get for
trying to out-tech a teenager.
I was at the show.
- Why, you're not funny.
You asshole.
Asshole.